there's this staple of late night
television that's just been around for I
don't know 4050 years
it's man-on-the-street comedy you know
what I'm talking about
you you go out in the street you put a
camera in someone's face the ask about
history or politics or pop culture and
then they can't answer the question
right and everyone just starts laughing
cuz it's just funny in America to see
how dumb people are that's what we like
if we like that it's work if you what it
works it works every single time we
thought we got to get it on this we
never did that yeah trying to mix things
up but let's stick with one of the
classics so once again we did it one
other time we did just that check this
out what is the name of the former Trump
campaign manager who is currently in
prison Paul Manafort and which foreign
lobbying law did he violate the foreign
agents Registration Act which requires
people who are acting as agents on
behalf of foreign principles to make
periodic public disclosure and how often
must foreign lobbyists disclose to the
Department of Justice annually it's
semi-annually what is tort law tort law
refers to a lawsuit with the aim of
compensating the aggrieved party of a
civil wrong for any damages suffered and
what are the three main types of torts
negligence strict or product liability
and intentional torts and what are the
seven types of intentional torts battery
assault intentional infliction of
emotional distress conversion false
imprisonment trespass to land and crap I
can't remember the seven trusted
channels you toured idiot
calculate pi to xx decimal place
3.14159265 three five eight nine seven
nine three two three eight four five
wrong
it's 3.14159265 three five eight nine
seven nine three two three eight four
six good what are the two main types of
dinosaurs or netha skia or bird hip
dinosaurs and thesaurus kia or lizard
hipped dinosaurs correct
[Applause]